[Music]
nothing epitomizes market failures more
than the cost of insulin in july
california governor gavin newsom
announced a first in the nation plan for
the golden state to make its own insulin
california is now taking matters into
our own hands the state is getting into
the insulin business because of high
prices
in 2020 the average out-of-pocket
spending by medicare part d enrollees
was 54 per insulin prescription that
comes to an average annual cost of
dollars these high prices have made the
us a global outlier today americans pay
about eight times more for their insulin
than the rest of the developed world
insulin has really been one of the
poster child examples of drug prices run
amok all of the entities in these supply
chains are
for-profit
companies
and so they are looking out for their
shareholders none of them has a
fiduciary responsibility to patients so
why is insulin so expensive in the u.s
and could california's plan to curb
insulin costs actually work
discovered just over a hundred years ago
in 1921 insulin is a life-saving drug
essential for the survival of about 7.4
million diabetic americans or roughly 2
percent of the u.s population before
insulin diabetes especially type 1
diabetes was often fatal and lifespans
were much shorter part of the reason
insulin is so expensive is due to the
nature of the insulin market which is
controlled by three insulin
manufacturers together these companies
produce almost 100 of the insulin supply
in the u.s
a representative from novo nordisk wrote
in an email we know that not one single
solution will work for everyone and
continue to develop programs to ensure
people with diabetes can get the insulin
medication they need in a separate
statement a representative from eli
lilly wrote in an email lily is deeply
committed to insulin affordability and
has long advocated for holistic
sustainable policy solutions such as
passing through rebates directly to
people who use insulin and limiting
out-of-pocket costs that can
significantly help people who use
insulin insulin is complex to
manufacture and the regulatory pathway
for low-cost versions of biologic drugs
in the u.s is less well established and
so you don't see a lot of strong
competition a 2021 senate investigation
also identified middlemen called
pharmacy benefit managers or pbms for
contributing to the increases the
insulin supply chain involves numerous
players in a complicated web of
relationships within this system pbms
are the third-party intermediaries that
negotiate prices between drug
manufacturers insurance companies and
pharmacies list price for a drug is the
sticker price that is set by the
manufacturer sort of like an automobile
would have a manufacturer's suggested
retail price
but like automotives the list price
isn't what most people end up paying for
that professor karen van nuys is an
assistant professor at usc who recently
published a study about insulin
affordability after the list price is
set manufacturers pay a whole bunch of
discounts and rebates and coupons and
fees back to people in the in the
distribution system
and then the manufacturer what the
manufacturer ends up taking
from that is the list price minus all of
those discounts and rebates and fees and
that's known as the net price in 2019
the average net price for diabetes
medications produced by the drug maker
sanofi was 62
but the average list price was 361
a spokesperson from sanofi wrote in an
email despite rhetoric about insulin
prices the net price of insulin has
fallen for seven consecutive years pbms
have demanded rebates for pharmaceutical
products for nearly two decades and they
are an ingrained feature of our
healthcare system in recent years
america's high drug prices have spurred
startups seeking to deliver lower-cost
alternatives earlier this year
entrepreneur mark cuban launched the
mark cuban cost plus drug company an
online store that sells hundreds of
low-cost generic medications cuban's
model undercuts the traditional drug
supply chain by selling directly to
consumers and cutting out pbms another
company that could serve as a model for
california is civica rx a non-profit
established by a group of hospitals and
philanthropic groups similar to cuban
startup civica undercuts the established
system by cutting out pbms but it also
plans to lower costs by bypassing the
major drug makers we've had early
conversations from from the very
beginning what the state of california
is you know they're going through their
selection process to find a partner to
do this and you know we wish the state
of california well and frankly would be
delighted to partner with them should it
come to that dan lilliandquist is the
chief architect behind civica we only
answer the markets where we feel like
there's distortion in the market where
the markets are functioning well and
prices are stable and patients are have
accessible drugs we'll never enter those
markets but when we see a failure in an
abuse
this is a market regulating function in
the sense that we will intervene in
those markets bring competition
to to help force
market
mechanisms to correct the problem civica
seeks to disrupt the traditional drug
supply chain with a model known as a
healthcare utility the concept is built
on a membership structure in which
different hospital systems partner
together to purchase generic drugs from
either their own in-house manufacturer
or a subcontractor since launching in
september of 2018 civica is now
producing 64 generic drugs in march the
non-profit announced it will begin
manufacturing and distributing low-cost
insulin to its patients by early 2024.
we're building a 140 000 square foot
manufacturing facility in petersburg
virginia which will be online later this
year and in that facility we'll be able
to make a hundred percent of the vile
capacity for insulin for the country
civica says it plans to produce three
generic insulins and vials and
pre-filled pens pricing to consumers
will be no more than thirty dollars per
vial and fifty five
for five penn cartridges if civica or
other players introduced low-cost
insulin it would affect um
how the established players operate i
think they would have to accept lower
profit margins than what they've been
used to so far to reduce its insulin
costs california is attempting to
circumvent the established market
california will spend 100 million
dollars in this year's budget 50 million
dollars to develop low-cost insulin the
other half would be used to set up an
in-state insulin manufacturing facility
because the state is involved and
because the state does not plan to make
a
profit from this
they want to make this available at a
very low cost newsome's administration
has not announced all of the details of
its plan including when its insulin will
be available and how much it will cost
but a tweet from the governor's office
noted that many americans pay between
300 and 500 a month for the drug and
that with california's insulin that cost
would at a minimum be cut in half
california's initiative comes as
washington moves forward with its own
insulin cost cutting measure and now
i'm going to take action that i've been
looking forward to doing for 18 months
on august 16th president biden signed
into law legislation to lower
prescription drug prices the law's most
immediate effects will start next year
when people on medicare will see their
insulin costs capped at
dollars a month
[Applause]
[Music]